the group that's stalking along here in
the middle of the night is armed
silently the men and women take up
positions in the center of hamburg in
front of a church
are you ready
take your places lights on
it's an ambush with light
the christ church which is usually not
illuminated at night is effectively set
in scene
we want to draw attention to this place
to this building and its historical
facade the effect would probably be very
different if it were illuminated
professionally but this is what we can
achieve with our lamps these gorilla
weapons
these nighttime maneuvers are called
gorilla lighting
young lighting designers organize these
events flash mob style they get the
lamps choose their targets and film the
activities
they raise the question of where light
can and should be used effectively
guerrilla lighting is a revolution with
light
and the city of hamburg got the message
it started dispatching people like this
man to check out how bright the lights
of hamburg are at night
some shops have signs that really burn
into your eyes
i measure the light density in candelas
per square meter
that's the measurement for brightness as
perceived by the human eye
here i get a light density of 3 000
candelas per square meter 3 to 400
candelas per square meter would be
enough to draw attention to this apple
logo
to a toy
for two years hamburg wrote letters
informing apple of the light pollution
the company refused to take action
our own inquiries to apple get a similar
answer no comment
in many cities there's a real lighting
war underway in the competition for
customers attention
but most of the light shines upwards
from space we can see that street lights
in particular shine in the wrong
direction
the result is that you can hardly see
the stars anymore in cities
without light pollution the night sky in
hamburg could look like this
but it's not just about seeing the stars
it's also about the health and
well-being of urban dwellers
researchers at berlin's sanctedvik
hospital are studying their patients
sleep patterns
during their night shifts the doctors
use themselves as guinea pigs subjected
to special lighting situations
after the light exposure they study
their own sleep
patterns small amounts of light which
we're exposed to everywhere in daily
life can lead to measurable changes in
physiology including in the structure of
the brain
the list of diseases caused by
artificial light ranges from depression
to diabetes and even cancer
there's a high probability that for
people who are already predisposed to
developing these illnesses artificial
light is the thing that tips the balance
that's why peta andres hamburg's city
lighting advisor is calling for
intelligent concepts for preserving the
darkness of night
the fact that lights are not turned down
in the evening and the eye is much much
more sensitive and the light draws a lot
of insects
that creates a level of light pollution
which is not acceptable
the fighters from gorilla lighting are
looking for their next target
if light and therefore precious energy
were saved elsewhere other parts of the
city could really be seen in their best
light